hey this is presh talwalkar
here's a slightly edited version of an
email i received
i follow your youtube channel and you
are great
i've created a puzzle you might like
a cyclist ascends a long climb at a
constant speed of 18 kilometers per hour
a motorcycle rally starts one minute
after the cyclist
every minute for the entire day
a motorcycle starts the same long climb
and goes until it reaches the end of the
climb which is the finishing line for
the motorcycles
when the cyclist reaches the top of the
long climb
he arrives at the same time as a
motorcycle that is reaching the
finishing line
the cyclist then turns around
and descends to the starting point of
the climb with double the speed of his
ascent
the cyclist keeps track of when
motorcycles pass him
by funny coincidence
the number of motorcycles that overtook
him on his ascent
exactly equals the number of motorcycles
that pass by him on his descent
all motorcycles have the same constant
average speed
the question is
what is the speed of a motorcycle
alessio from italy
at first it seems like this problem is
impossible to solve there just doesn't
seem to be enough information
and yet
if you follow through the calculations
carefully you will be able to solve this
problem
so
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so i'm actually going to present two
different ways to solve this problem and
i do encourage you to stick with the
video because the second method
involving geometry is a lot of fun
i'll first go through algebraic
equations and then i'll present a
geometry visualization
so let's get started with the algebra
let's set up some notation
let's write ta to be the time the
cyclist takes in minutes for the ascent
we'll write va
for the speed of the cyclist in
kilometers per minute for the ascent
we'll write td and vd
for the analogous variables for the
cyclist descent
we'll also write tm
and vm for the motorcycle's time and
speed for the climb
we'll write s for the length of the
climb going from the bottom to the top
or the top to the bottom and right n to
be the number of motorcycles overtaken
on the ascent or number of motorcycles
passed on the descent
so with that setup let's solve this
problem
because time is equal to distance
divided by speed
t a is equal to s over v a
and t m is equal to s over v m
when the cyclist reaches the top after
exactly ta minutes
he reaches at the same time as a
motorcycle which started at the bottom
tm minutes prior
hence the last motorcycle to pass the
cyclist on the way up started the race
at the minute mark t a minus tm
all motorcycles starting before this
time also passed the cyclist
so motorcycles leaving at minute marks
one two three and all the way to ta
minus tm
all pass the cyclist
so we can conclude n is equal to t a
minus tm
now let's solve for a similar equation
for n on the descent
during the descent the cyclist will pass
motorcycles for two different cases
the cyclist will pass
one all motorcycles that have already
started but not yet past the cyclist and
two
all motorcycles that started the rally
during the cyclist's descent so let's
solve for each case
for the first case
notice the cyclist has taken ta minutes
to ascend
so ta motorcycles started the rally
during the cyclist's ascent
but n of these which equals t a minus tm
have already passed the cyclist
so there will be t a minus the quantity
t a minus t m
which simplifies to be tm motorcycles
that have started but not yet past the
cyclist
now for case two we need to consider the
time of the decent
this will be equal to the length of the
climb divided by the speed of the
descent
now the speed of the descent is given to
be twice the speed of the ascent
so this simplifies
to be
half the time of the ascent
so it will take the cyclist
td which equals ta over 2 minutes to
descend
so exactly another ta over 2 motorcycles
will start the race because a motorcycle
starts the race every single minute
so we add up these two cases to get n is
equal to tm
plus ta over 2.
so we now have two different expressions
for n
and we need to set them equal to each
other
so let's go ahead and do that
we can now solve this equation for tm in
terms of ta
we get that tm is equal to ta divided by
four
in other words the motorcycle completes
the ascent in one fourth the time it
takes the cyclist
consequently
we can solve that the motorcycle speed
is equal to 4 times that
of the cyclist speed on the ascent
therefore
since the cyclist ascends at 18
kilometers per hour the motorcycle has a
speed of 4 times 18 which is 72
kilometers per hour
and like magic we've solved
for the answer without knowing the exact
number of motorcycles and without
knowing the elevation of the client
so this is one way to solve the problem
but there's another way
that involves a geometry visualization
so let's plot as follows we have time on
the horizontal axis
and the elevation of the person on the
climb on the vertical axis
so one graph will be a linear graph to
the top of the climb for the cyclist
ascent
now the remaining portion of the
cyclist's trip will be the descent going
back to the zero elevation
since the cyclist has twice the descent
speed the same elevation is covered in
half the time
so if the cyclist takes t minutes to
ascend the climb
the cyclist takes t over two minutes to
descend
so the total amount of time will be
three halves t
now what about the motorcycles
well every minute a motorcycle starts
and goes to the top of the climb
we can visualize this as a series of
lines
that start every single minute and go to
the top of the elevation
each intersection of a green line and a
blue line is when the motorcycle passes
the cyclist
we know
that there are the same number on the
ascent as the descent
so there will be n lines for the ascent
equally spaced at one minute apart
and there will be n lines for the
descent equally spaced at one minute
apart
putting this together
we have that there will be equal time to
the left of this line
and an equal time to the right of this
line
the motorcycle that reaches exactly
when the cyclist reaches the top
divides this graph into n minutes on the
left and n minutes on the right
so this line divides the graph into two
triangles of equal area because both
triangles have the same base of n and
the same height as the elevation of the
climb
consequently since the entire base is
three halves t
each base of these smaller triangles
will be half that length which is
three-fourths t
so each of these lengths will be three t
over four
now recall that the cyclist takes t
minutes to reach the top
and t over two minutes to descend
so we can use these values
to deduce the lengths
between when the motorcycle starts
and
reaches the top
so this particular length will be t over
4.
now how is this useful to us
well notice that the motorcycle ascends
the climb in t over four minutes
while the cyclist does the same ascent
in a time of t
so we can use these times to deduce that
the green line has a slope that's four
times as large as the blue line
therefore the motorcycle speed is four
times larger than the cyclist speed on
the ascent so it is equal to four times
18 which equals 72 kilometers per hour
so like magic we figured out the answer
geometrically
what's also nice about this geometric
visualization
is that it also shows why the elevation
doesn't matter
the shapes and slopes will scale even if
we change the elevation
so imagine we have
an elevation that's shorter
well the entire graph is going to scale
and we're still going to get the same
relative speed of the motorcycle to the
cycle
so for any elevation the green line
slope is four times as large as the blue
line and the motorcycle speed will be
four times larger to be 72 kilometers
per hour
so i like this method because it's a
little bit easier to see exactly what's
going on and why the elevation doesn't
matter
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
if you like this video you can check out
my books which are linked in the video
description
you can also support me on patreon and
you can catch me on social media either
at mindyourdecisions or at presh
talwalkar